imagine wanting to go on a relaxing
summer vacation flying from los angeles
to the bahamas but then you're trying to
book a flight ticket right off the bat
there aren't any large booking sites
available the ones that do exist are
small patchy and unreliable as there is
no direct flight you have to book your
tickets separately on airlines websites
la air is the only operator in
california and it only flies to dallas
and it isn't allowed in random states
airspaces so the trip is incredibly long
and inconvenient from dallas you have
texas air flying to chicago minneapolis
and new york only with transfer times of
2 minutes 5 minutes and 12 hours
respectively from chicago you could take
a plane to jacksonville with illinois
air from where florida has a direct
connection with the bahamas but it costs
8 000 and the transit times are too
short from minneapolis there's a
propeller plane to miami but the trip
takes 20 hours and costs 5 000 and then
from miami you still need to take a boat
from new york there's a plane to
philadelphia from there there's a plane
to washington and then a plane to
charlotte and then plane to tampa where
after eight hours of waiting you'll be
able to get on the top of bahamas plane
tickets aren't available online from
philadelphia from then on you have to
get them in person at each airport time
spent 6 hours temps open 30. mental
health dangerously low chosen method of
transportation screw that you're driving
on that beautiful straight six-lane
highway linking los angeles directly to
the bahamas and this is what it very
often feels like to travel by european
international rail in 2021 the european
year of rail a promotional train the
connecting europe express traveled
across europe to popularize rail travel
but what was intended as a nice and easy
pr stunt became an absolute disaster the
train crossed 26 national borders almost
all of which resulted in a complete stop
getting through the european rail
network required three different trains
pulled by 55 different locomotives
that's because the european
international rail network is a complete
mess hang on a second isn't europe
supposed to have an accident rail system
fast and convenient trains running to
almost every town and city yes that is
indeed the case
domestically but as soon as you try to
traverse a border you find yourself in a
unique heartburn-inducing hellscape
called european international rail where
attempting to book a ticket can actually
cause mental health issues and so in
this video we'll be touching on the
following points the problems of
international rail the ones responsible
for sad problems what is being done to
fix this mess and what more could be
done before the climate crystal hits us
and we'll have a 2050 refugee crisis
times 50 triggering the largest foreign
resurgence in the history of no get your
hands off me so as i've said while
domestic train travel in europe is
generally great travelling across state
borders by training can actually erode
your mental well-being but thankfully
fabulous is an app that can help you
avoid just that the sponsor of today's
video fabulous is your digital coach a
happiness trainer so to speak it's the
number one self-care app out there to
help you build better habits and achieve
your goals fabulous really helped me
maintain my mental health after
traveling by train from amsterdam to
prague oh boy based on behavioral
science it helps you develop great
healthy habits and routines backed up by
science for a healthier more productive
and fulfilling lifestyle the app will
help you create your own rituals these
small steps that lead to big changes the
two main ways to use the app are habit
tracking and dedicated programs in heavy
tracking you can choose from 100 plus
recommended habits or you can create
your own fabulous then lets you build
these habits with gentle reminders and
content based on behavioral science
dedicated programs help you achieve your
well-being goals over the course of
several weeks the new habits you pick up
can be added to your daily routine if
you so choose the app even sends you
nice letters weekly reviews and monthly
self-care checklists and how nice is
that with the premium version you can
build and improve and unlimited number
of habits in your routines and you have
access to all programs and exercises
start building your ideal daily routine
the first 500 people who click the link
will get 25 of their fabulous
subscription thank you for checking out
fabulous ads like this help support what
i do and now back to the video not long
ago i traveled from germany to amsterdam
the trip there was relatively uneventful
i traveled to hanover from where i took
a direct train to amsterdam central
neighboring countries generally have
their cross-border rail travel figured
out somewhat the problem started on the
way back where i made the terrible
mistake of trying to go from amsterdam
to prague only 17 hours and seven
changes for 99.90 i ended up taking the
night jet the sleeper version of the
rail jet operated by the austrian
railways as i was going to prague i
booked my ticket through the czech
railways app muay vlog got on the train
and
so i'm on the night jet from amsterdam
to germany and uh
well it's a sleeper train but uh i got
my place reserved in a regular
compartment car because
i reserved through the czech railways
application which cannot differentiate
between
beds and seats and there's this i don't
know if you can hear it
imagine sleeping next to a hairdryer
i had to get off in reagan's borg at 505
to catch the train to prague at 6 15. if
i miss it the next connection is in 2
hours with one change or in 4 hours
without a change you have 1 hour and 10
minutes to catch your connection your
train is now 2 hours late your ticket is
only valid for the 6 15 train so if you
miss it you have to buy a new ticket
sleep well on a regular seat for 9 hours
i wrote a complaint to the czech
railways i talked to the manager if you
will to which i got the following
response we are sorry but movieblock
cannot sell bad you can use our eshop or
at the stations well guess that's my
fault should have educated myself on the
particularities of the train ticket app
before using it to buy a train ticket in
the end luckily the train did manage to
work down his delay and i caught my
connection to prague traveling on the
munich prague mainline part of the
backbone european rail network which is
an unelectrified single track in the
shadow of the d5 highway going parallel
so the problems of european
international rail it's under investment
into infrastructure right not only i'm
afraid in fact that's the least of our
worries remember the connecting europe
express having had to put three
different sets with 55 different
locomotives we call that
interoperability which is a magic word
in railway circles in order for
interoperability to happen you need four
main things to be in order track gauge
electrification system train control
system and the end user experience in
terms of track gauge we're doing rather
well most of everything is 1435
millimeter standard gauge ireland isn't
the problem because it's an island
spain's sprawling high speed network is
standard gauge for the baltics there's
the rheya baltic project underway
linking them with standard gauge finland
is far away anyway belarus and russia
are no go zones and the moldova in
ukraine will likely make an effort to
convert their network to standard gauge
after the russian invasion so hey that's
neat one out of four done but then [ __ ]
this is an approximate map of
electrification systems in europe your
electric train has to be fitted for a
given system or it cannot go there the
standard is 25 kilovolt 50hz ac by the
way mark green germany switzerland and
austria use a different system though
forming a 15 kilovolt ac island in the
middle of the continent we also have a
bunch of three kilowatt dc countries and
the netherlands exotic 1.5 kilowatt dc
also present in the south of france
meaning if you want to run a train
across europe you're potentially looking
at four system trains to do so and those
trains are very rare and expensive and
someone should hurry and tell deutsche
bahn because those brand new hyper
modern ic for high speed trains are 15
kilovolt ac only the third issue is
train control systems
yeah if you want to run a train from one
country to the other your train has to
have the proper hardware what you're
looking at right now is a map of the
dozens of different systems currently
operating in europe and well let's
return to this later here's a great
example of what these issues mean in
practice here we have a local train line
running between room burke and jacquin
and the czech republic going through
germany for about half the way so how
does this line operate first off only
half of it is electrified between
jacquin and barchanda second the double
track also ends with the electrification
continuing on from much under a single
track third the electrified section is
15 kilovolt ac on the german side and 3
kilovolt dc on the check side the check
side will be converted to 25 kilovolt ac
in the coming years and the german side
will be converted a few years before the
sun turns into a supernova fourth train
control systems between roomwork and the
border there is mirelle on the german
side there's pzb90 and from the border
to jichin i have no idea maybe also pcb
but the border to ejection section will
also be converted to standard ertms soon
that's european rail traffic management
system so yeah as a result of this
cluster [ __ ] you can't run a proper
train service with electric multiple
units the line has to be served with
small siemens digital diesel multiple
units running at 2 hour intervals making
this more of a tourist line than an
actual competitive mass transit system
so if you ever wondered why european
cross-border train services are bad
that's the idea there are also other
more obscure barriers such as an
operator's rolling stock having to get
approval to run on another country's
rails but now there is a common european
framework for that so if you abide by
those rules you can automatically run on
every rail network in europe but
national operators are of course in no
rush to implement it and the first
operator to receive european
certification was none other than the
hungarian railways by the way for their
new domestically manufactured ic
passenger cars but aside from all the
hardware issues there is the fourth one
what i call user experience this is an
issue just as severe as the previous
ones with a key difference this would
actually be easy to fix like very easy
and rather cheap and it could be done
very quickly and it would make rail far
more competitive with airplanes and cars
in an instant i'm talking about a
unified european train ticketing service
a web page uniting every single line of
everyday operator just like flight
booking websites so uh can we do it
no
all right then turns out most national
rail operators keep most of their
ticketing data closed meaning no third
party website can access them if you
ever wondered why there aren't any
websites where you can book train
tickets from anywhere to anywhere like
with airplanes this is why airlines are
obligated to publish their ticketing
data to third parties national train
operators in europe aren't as written in
this investigate europe article the
european parliament actually voted
overwhelmingly for open ticketing data
in october 2018 only to be denied by the
council of ministers comprised of member
state governments national rail
operators refused to give up their
precious little turfs and that's why you
have to spend two hours booking an
international train ticket on four
different websites or having to download
six different apps compared to booking a
flight ticket on one website in 10
minutes another issue is passenger
rights if your flight is cancelled in
some cases airlines can be obligated to
even offer you a hotel room if you miss
your connecting train of a different
operator and you have to spend the night
at the station your compensation is
still having your phone and wallets on
you when you wake up on the platform
bench in the morning a solution to this
would be through tickets meaning a
journey of multiple operators considered
as one single ticket few train companies
offer through tickets today writes the
european commission in the passenger
rights proposal and when railway
companies only sell tickets for journey
segments not the whole trip it allows
them to bypass obligations related to
compensation rerouting and assistance
huh i wonder if countries supported the
france germany and spain were the main
opponents of any obligation on railway
companies to offer through tickets the
council did not accept this under any
circumstances as they consider that the
sector is not yet sufficiently prepared
to issue through tickets hey you know
what else we are not sufficiently
prepared for climate change through
tickets but that would mean we'd have
actual obligations towards passengers we
can't do that people can drive instead i
guess gee why is it so hot this summer
anyway on a lighter note compared to the
us a great benefit of living in the eu
is that large systemic problems like
this are actually being resolved
gradually however the direction is more
or less correct usually and the only
question is the speed of implementation
i.e funding and political will so what
is being done to fix the chronic
problems of european international rail
the track gauge issue is mostly resolved
especially with the robotica project
mentioned in the beginning where a
standard gauge high speed double track
will be built through the baltics with a
potential future connection to helsinki
through a proposed undersea rail tunnel
i also suspect that countries like
ukraine and moldova will make at least
some effort to convert to standard gauge
for obvious reasons in terms of
electrification the main effort is
converting dc systems to 25 kilovolt ac
this involves individual main lines like
the brussels luxembourg which just got
put back into operation or entire
country networks like the czech republic
set to completely switch all their 1800
kilometers of dc lines to ac in the next
two decades with the first of these
conversions already finished in june
2022 otherwise new lines especially high
speed lines are usually built using 25
kilovolt ac the train control system
issue despite being a gigantic
[ __ ] is being solved through
ertms or european rail traffic
management system which is supposed to
unify the entire european network it's
slow it's over budget and france may or
may not be sabotaging its implementation
in an effort to hinder competition but
it's happening nonetheless whenever
there is a major line reconstruction for
example it usually gets switched to
ertms and this is important because it's
just a plain better system if you outfit
a line with it you're looking at a 10 to
20 capacity increase just by virtue of
having a more efficient system the rtms
has three levels each having more
function than the previous to the point
where level 2 and 3 basically means
self-driving trains as for user
friendliness like a unified ticketing
system i predict that the next few
summers with their even more violent and
deadly heat waves will reinvigorate
discussion hopefully maybe before it's
uh too late you know for now i think the
goal we should strive towards is this
have every major city connected by
standard gauge rail that's easy every
main line should be converted to 25
kilovolt ac outside of germany austria
and switzerland because let's face it
they'll never do it have every main line
operate on ertms this is already
partially happening and give the same
rights and ticketing services to rail
passengers that airline passengers
currently have at that point we'll have
a neat competitive international rail
system on which we should run multiple
units or trains with control cars so the
train can go both ways and doesn't need
changing locomotives when changing
directions so basically either stuff
like debuss new double-decker ics or the
uber's rail jets but the former is
better so let's have that and then run
those trains on major lines between 5
and 22 at the minimum one hour intervals
so not like the berlin prague line where
trains go every two hours with the last
one leaving at 17.05 come on people
seriously though forget about
conventional locomotive hull trains in
inter-city traffic and just forget about
them in general get multiple units or at
the very least push-pulls those are the
trains with the control cars and vote
for politicians who are progressive on
the rail issue which is usually your
local green party or any other party not
composed entirely of car-centric
grandpas and with that i thank you for
watching this was my video on european
international rail lots of potential
lots of room to improve god knows we
need it so let's hope for the best also
if you want to support me making this
kind of content please consider
subscribing to my patreon link in the
description and i'll be seeing you next
time